[Music]  Blake Lively's stuns on the September  2017 issue of glamour I feel good  inside the mag she gets candid about her  home life with hubby Ryan Reynolds  saying it's nonsense that people think  her life is perfect then what you see in  the media is not real life quote the  night before an interview I have  complete anxiety how is this person  going to spin me they pick narratives  for everyone that wouldn't happen in  real life the 29 year old also shoots  down that perfect perception in her own  way by saying she loves Ryan most of the  time quote if I say I'm so in love with  him all the time then you get that eye  rolling Oh her life is so great she's so  perfect so it's like my defense  mechanism as for all of Ryan's comedic  tweets about their daughters Blake says  everything is a completely made-up  scenario he'll run them by me sometimes  just to make me laugh I've always been a  little cheeky